وهذه صور مباشره من العاصمه الارجنتينيه
بيونسيه
لاحتفالات الجماهير الارجنتينيه بتحقيق
منتخب بلادها للنجمه الثالثه في كاس
العالم المونديال الثالث
طبعا المونديال الثالث للارجنتين والتي
حققته بعد ان كسبت المنتخب الفرنسي بركلات
الترجيح بعد مباراه مشوقه ومثيره كان
ليونيل ميسي هو بطلها الاول والوحيد
الارجنتين ايضا توجت بهذا اللقب مشاهدينا
بعد ان فازت به في المره الاخيره عام
1986 كسبته في مونديال قطر 2002 2020
اضافت النجمه الثالثه اصبحت الارجنتين
تملك ثلاثه القاب عالميه طبعا اعلنا اليوم
بانه يوم اجازه رسميه في الارجنتين
احتفالا بالمنتخب الارجنتيني الذي طلب من
قطر الى بوينس ايريس هذا اليوم وهذه
الاحتفالات وسط العاصمه الارجنتينيه
والساينس